reports of American and British
intelligence spying on Chancellor Angela
Merkel from their embassy rooftops in
Berlin our headline news at the moment
the media had been discussing the idea
of Edward Snowden currently in Moscow
being granted political asylum in
Germany we wanted to gauge opinion on
the street he speaks the truth so why
not take him in giving Snowden asylum in
Germany just because the stories come
out I'm skeptical card ready Snuggie I
say no because our long-term relations
with the US would be compromised I'll
get the next myth machardie prefer store
my fear is that he'd be extradited and I
don't want that I'd like to hear more of
what he has to say good an online survey
suggests that a majority of Germans are
in favor of granting Snowden asylum
eighty-one percent while seventeen
percent are against the idea and what do
people make of Snowden revealing state
secrets good it's good he's a brave man
it's a great thing by kind of newburgh
wisdom hi Ellie what's certain is that
he's become a traitor in the eyes of the
US but you always have to try something
or else it could end badly as far as
consistent as the session ojala me it's
treason really but he is also disclosing
things that we hadn't really imagined
before hand in a way we can be grateful
to him zofran kimani multan paws on
61 percent of those surveyed welcome
Snowden's revelations seventeen percent
say it was wrong with 22% not sure or
indifferent Snowden's asylum in Russia
was granted for just one year it remains
to be seen where he will be by the time
that runs out next summer